the Joe Rogan experience what do you
have thoughts on this what's happening
now with space travel where it's
transferring into the public sector or
the private sector rather instead of
being something that the government
handles now it's private companies is
that a good thing it's a great thing is
that yeah because first of all it's not
quite that black and white in the media
it's all portrayed as commercial space
and like these private companies are
taken over the truth is at least for the
human orbital spaceflight that we're
doing at SpaceX and that Boeing is doing
with with their vehicle it's a part it's
a public-private partnership and so NASA
is working very closely with both those
companies and we're working together and
in a way it's not really that different
from the way it's always been you know
like NASA didn't have a nasa factory
that built the Saturn 5 rocket is built
here by like McDonnell Douglas and North
American Rockwell built if I remember at
North American built and built a command
module and and the lunar lander was
built by Grumman so those were all
private companies they're contractors
but they're still private companies and
what's happening now is just a slight
change to the relationship between NASA
and the private companies when NASA's
not micromanaging quite as much as they
used to they're saying okay here's our
top level requirements we want you to
get four people up and down to the space
station that's a bit of a simplification
because actually the requirements
document is like there are thousands of
requirements but they're but they don't
go down and tell you how to meet each
requirement they leave it up to you so
now SpaceX there's a lot more room to
innovate then like North American
Rockwell did when when they built the
vehicles back during Apollo so that that
and the other thing that's different is
that the funding the way the NASA is
paying its firm fixed price you know is
that like the Space Shuttle when we
build an aircraft carrier it's its cost
plus contracting which has been terribly
abused and has been horrible for the US
taxpayer it what it says to the company
is you can it could cost whatever costs
that's what we'll pay and in fact we'll
give you a profit as a percentage of the
cost so like you're in it your incentive
as the companies like to make the cost
as high as you can so
your profit as high as I can but that's
ridiculous yeah so it's not cool and and
but it they had to do it that way like
during World War two is when this
started because like nobody knew how
much it was gonna cost to build a p-51
Mustang because nobody did one before
hmm
so they came up with this mechanism but
now it's kind of been abused now we're
using it to do things that we've done
before and then the third thing is that
that the companies own the intellectual
property so what that means is like
Rockwell they built the Space Shuttle
couldn't like build a new Space Shuttle
like build like Space Shuttle enterprise
or something and then go sell tickets on
it they weren't allowed to but we can so
we can we're gonna build this dragon
we're gonna take Bob banking and Doug
Hurley two friends of mine are gonna be
the first astronauts to ride it to the
space station and once we meet our NASA
NASA is our number one customer they're
paying the bill so once they are
satisfied we can then go make another
one and sell tickets and take you know
private individuals so really that's the
key difference and I really think that
2020 we're gonna look back at 2020 as a
year that everything changed really yeah
because the all those dreams of science
fiction I like being able to take your
vacations around the rings of Saturn and
like all the like private space stations
all that kind of stuff that we grew up
hoping would happen when we were older I
think it's really finally starting
because this is this is the beginning of
that infrastructure that that private
sector commercial infrastructure and and
and ability to actually get it done
[Applause]